we've now thought a lot about the orange
juice market at least at a firm specific
level we in the last few videos we
talked about what our average total
costs and average variable costs and
marginal costs are if we are running an
orange juice making business now let's
think about what happens at the market
level so we're going to go back to some
of what we've thought about in the past
in terms of just supply and demand
curves so this is the orange
orange juice
orange juice market
and let's just draw some supply and
demand curves right over here so this is
going to be
this is going to be the price per gallon
price
price per
gallon
and let's say that this right over here
is one dollar
this right over here is 50 cents
and this is 0
0 and let's say that this is the
quantity
quantity in gallons per week and gallons
per week and we're going to talk about
the entire orange juice market so this
is going to be millions of gallons per
week
millions
millions of gallons
per week
per
week
and that is let's say this is one
two
three
four
five
and six
and let's just say and i'm going to
simplify it relative to what we saw in
the last video let's just say that the
supply curve for the orange juice market
and i'll be careful this time this is
the near-term supply curve or the
short-term supply curve looks like looks
something like this that is the supply
curve and this is the entire market
these are all of the orange juice
producers so get to make them produce
even that first gallon it looks like
they need about 20 cents for that first
gallon and then each incremental gallon
they need more and more money the
marginal cost of that incremental gallon
for the market as a whole is going
higher and higher and higher they have
to get oranges from further away and
transport them further and further so
this right over here is a supply curve
or you could view it as the marginal
cost
marginal cost curve
now let's just draw an arbitrary demand
curve here so the demand curve let's say
it looks something like this
say that's our current demand
that is our current demand curve and now
what i'm going to add to this
is i'm going to add the price at which
firms the suppliers of the orange juice
make our neutral with returns to
economic profit or when economic profit
is equal to zero so let's say right over
here which happens to be our current
equilibrium price
this is the price so 50 cents per gallon
this is the price at which economic
profit is zero so i'll just write
economic
economic profit
is equal to zero and i want to remind
you economic profit being zero does not
mean that the accounting profit is zero
people could be making money at this
price it just says that they're neutral
whether or not they should be doing this
business that the amount of money that
they're making is roughly comparable to
their opportunity cost to be doing other
things
so when i say economic profit is zero
sometimes that's called the normal
profit when economic profit is zero this
is the price at which people are neutral
between shutting down and starting up
their business if you have positive
economic profit that means that more
people will want to go into this market
and if you have negative economic profit
that means that people are going to want
to essentially use up their fixed
expenses their equipment and any labor
contracts they might have and then go
out of business so this is where this is
that point right over there now let's
think of a couple of scenarios let's say
a research paper comes out and in that
research paper for whatever reason you
know we don't know if it was well done
research it says oranges are bad for you
for whatever reason so when the research
paper comes out says oranges are bad for
you what happens to demand well at any
given price demand will go down at any
given price demand will go down and the
new demand curve might look something
like this
now in the near term we have a new
equilibrium price and we have a new
equilibrium quantity this was the old
equilibrium price that the way i set it
up would just happen to be the price at
which economic profit is zero and this
was our old equilibrium quantity a
little over 3 million gallons a week now
we have a new lower equilibrium price we
have a new lower equilibrium price i
don't know this looks like about 40
cents per gallon and we have a new lower
equilibrium quantity now what happens at
this price obviously in the near term
people are willing to produce there
because that's their that's where their
marginal cost is so as when we saw in
multiple videos that someone's willing
to produce when the price is equal to
their marginal cost or they're willing
to produce a quantity up to when their
marginal cost is equal to the marginal
revenue or the price that they're going
to get
but i just said that they need to be
getting 50 cents a gallon in order to
make an economic profit now if they get
i don't know this looks like about 40
cents a gallon they're going to be
having an economic loss so no profit
no profit there and if there's no profit
there it really doesn't make sense for
them to continue or at least doesn't
make sense for all of them to continue
in that business so what's going to
happen is
that over time it will make sense for
them in the near term to produce to use
up they've already put in their costs
for their equipment and maybe labor
contracts and whatever else but over
time when prices are this low as people
use up their equipment there's no
incentive for them to buy new equipment
as the labor contracts expire there's no
incentive for them to renew the labor
contract as those things expire they're
just going to shut down the business and
so as they shut down the business as
they shut down the business two things
will happen quantity produced in the
market will go down and the price will
go up we will essentially move along
this curve until we get to this point
that's the point once the price is at 50
cents a gallon again then people are
neutral now they're not going to shut
down their firms so we're going to get
to this new equilibrium price and
equilibrium quantity in the long term in
the long term now let's think of another
situation instead of a newspaper report
saying that oranges are bad let's say a
newspaper report comes out saying
oranges are very good they make you live
longer they are the best thing that you
can have well then at any given price
you're going to have more demand and so
you would have a demand curve that looks
something like that
and then you'd have a higher equilibrium
quantity
and a higher equilibrium price
and people are going to be making since
the price is higher than the the price
at which the economic profit is zero
people are going to be making very
positive economic profits which makes
which means that there's a strong
incentive that people are neutral
between shutting down the business or
starting up the business at that point a
lot of people are are strongly motivated
to enter into the business so what's
going to happen is more and more people
are going to get more and more equipment
hire more and more people and as they do
that quantity is going to go up and so
and the price is going to go down and so
over the long term you're going to shift
back to this line once the price gets
down to that then there's no reason for
more people to enter they're kind of
neutral about it so what you see
happening is in the short term you would
look at where the demand curve
intersects with the short term supply
curve but in the long term you care
where it intersects with this kind of
horizontal line which is the price at
which economic profit is zero and that's
why you will hear and this is kind of a
more precise way of thinking about it
than we've done in the previous videos
this horizontal line right over here you
could view this as the long run
the long run
long run supply curve
long run supply curve and that says look
pretty much whatever
we will always produce over the long run
we will always produce whatever supply
is kind of necessary given that people
are neutral when it comes to economic
profit you go down here yes people will
try to use up their fixed costs but once
they're used up their fixed costs no
incentive for them to stay in business
then some of them go out of business
price goes up quantity goes down you get
back to the long run supply curve and
where that intersects with the demand
curve or if the opposite happens a lot
of economic profit a lot of entrance
into the market price goes down supply
goes up you get back to the long run
supply curve or i guess you could say
you go back to where the new demand
curve is intersecting the long run
supply curve